this is an eight news now breaking news
alert
town involvement of the traffic center
we wanted to let you know more about
what we know so far about a fire on the
valley's east side
this is on eastern just south of sahara
now the roads themselves are okay as far
as sahara is concerned it looks like
southbound eastern is for sure starting
to slow down
let's show you a live picture from the
regional transportation commission so
this is
eastern this is northbound eastern
there's the fire on the east side of the
street you can see
some of the smoke billowing up we do not
have any information yet on exactly what
is on fire
how this may have started how many folks
may be evacuated but
if you are northbound on eastern say
from flamingo coming up towards sahara
got to watch out for that emergency
equipment we do have a reporter on the
way to the scene so we'll get more
information for you and while we're
talking traffic let's update you on the
police activity that continues on desert
inn westbound
after paradise this is southbound
paradise that's fine
northbounders trying to make the left
turn onto westbound e.i those police
officers have been there for the better
part of three hours